when he landed was both the other table
not want young there you go
keep shooting if you finally bus out of
the Sun gets into a shooting window and
hit the three run take it down the lane
rider down baseline well this is one
heck of a shot ten picks and did not
materialise to their draft position over
the years there is a pretty regular
sprint of play a nice move by trade who
to speak the drive seeing his practice
the other day it was hands-on he was
energetic he was positive
[Applause]
there's three on getting
got to go his ability to make shots not
the question the question would be shots
next Atlanta was held to 12 first
quarter points and Bagley one versus two
there's the steal on the radio it's
inclusive the attacks reads the defense
terrific you have to do you got to go
search and seek out wisdom and whoo that
is deep there's some flash 11 points and
seeing a lot of different looks
defensively be bowling up top Cleveland
throws it down that's his ability to
trade up to look up the floor here
leader now I'm very young and I'm gonna
bring it out I'm gonna tell the pic not
to come nice beat by governor also we
have to learn [ __ ] right now
throws it down Conley six seconds five
beverage spooks it up spins in quarter
Trey beats the buzzer and hits the
three-pointer six seconds hustled it
down the floor got Garrett Teflon away
with a fake and buries the three of the
Hawks are back with it for
two teams trying to solve that riddle
here tonight over the top - Lenin okay
big body nice court it you have good
hands that time because Clarkson had his
hand on the ball but couldn't pry it
loose then see the beneficiary of the
all these whistles with free throws
great young again George Hill he's
getting behind tray and tray is gonna
make him pay and watch this trade three
I mean look ways that when he released
it
there's no defense there Dallas has only
got one wrapped in a possession ballgame
[Applause]
[Music]
that's a handle how about the spin Vince
gets him a little bit of separation the
close bike liebe my goodness I'll tell
you that's reminiscent of a handle like
Steph Curry but his favorite wasn't the
2017 draft last year played overseas
tray with a super loose man particularly
from distance he's 2 of 15 on Three's
tray young goes right to the hoop and
lays it in
[Music]
pray young
Wow winning this building way for
Atlanta Hawks commit to and six young
[Applause]
[Music]
prey leans in its I mean you got will
run more picking local roles with
Whiteside if you don't it's gonna be
tough
oh look at Kevin and assists number ten
comes right here I mean Matt Ryan would
be thrilled to see that pin Oh is that's
a pinpoint off shot there that was way
out
[Music]
Jones block I think Trey got a piece of
that one he got it on the way up there
it is a block shot for Trey young five
seconds for pray over midcourt Winslow
defending weights trailing it to
he's Houdini
they heat the trap right here but
there's three guys he goes between three
and meets a fourth guy at the rim nice
little floater to get his twentieth
point
[Applause]
did that go in like it's for dicks all
over if you get too
amp nice spin move back to his right
hand cancer a little bit too late
[Music]
hook and Durant hey Trey takes the
bounce pass away not a good pass there
by cool Trey gets into frets in the
corner good for three the good-looking
young Blair that's why he's in the store
in Lana Troy young with the rainbow is
getting long I mean this isn't almost
got you know a wide open three for Lin
sister for Trey young he is head ain't
game tonight very reluctant to take it
but he made it pray from just inside
[Applause]
pretty big guy there Trey quick shot
three good straight in
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
for a young that was an open three their
hand time to measure the scenes to shoot
that monster prints two and a half
minutes in Hawks looking to score
Trey goes baseline definite to hurt her
one second lap trach beats the buzzer
Trey young with 11 he comes up with this
hoop did it beat the buzzer a jerk did
Griffith stolen by Cray young
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
with 12 there again you getting a shot
right in the land you don't even look at
the basket Trey Young has an easy one
nine points for Trey gets it back from
Vince Carter pray against Osmond
oh the window on the reverse not giving
up on the drive that's just a nice drive
used to backboard just 43:27 steel by
Trey young in the passing lane
Carolina's twisting turning lead good
and a foul on Damari is bounced around
Portland his 16 is out last year
recovered from injury off the window and
good sorry young up to six common good
job just being right there
up for grabs but through the arms of
herder Baldwin has it blocked by Trey
and a shot clock violation and launched
this ball but is this that's too slow
getting that shot
short plot a drive to spray a floor
headset the power does float a nice
little hesitation there's two guys
they're too late up and in Negril austin
great picks it up leads the break Trey
it leaves it for harder off the
turnovers
I step back Trey young behind the back
to Kevin Alonzo Trier working on that
wing stolen by trail he's going to take
it up and it is rejected put it off the
glass or is it a foul tukoji chirping oh
gee
[Applause]
Wow
so Trey Young has now dribble between
two guys lay low teens right and
breakers before his way then
bounce for the dump and watch Brown on
this place or where's oh no way
I don't know he hadn't run anyway yet
he's at the rim Derrick Desmond throwing
one down rockin Samantha Hardy
remembrance on the basket ray shot clock
at three
platelets it's Lionhead set what a
rainbow three for three
shot clock winding down but he doesn't
let this one fly but again he got a
watch that right leg Devon and young
without standing saves great God puts it
in anything he went straight down the
middle of the lane
the play has beeline goes right at the
defense
window and death but knocks it away and
up by quarter trace pizza break spray
[Applause]
whoops the drive still for defin tray
for the lead
Brahe with seven six trains going to
launch from deep it looks like yep there
it comes
[Applause]
get water check it out
you gotta make them Alex went seven
second six my second stride try to want
it now goes up ladies the game just
weaves his way through all those white
shirts he goes from one end to the floor
to other no one cuts him off I mean he
gives by marking it right here look at
this drive to the lane I mean this is it
this is ridiculous
dead but rebounds lead pass
[Applause]
just another great pass from half that's
fancy
it's beyond half-court right on Clint
Troy's O'Neal latest baler he was a
teammate of torian's in college prey off
the glass at good he throws the entire
interior deep back to the jams move one
more time from Trey young you see the
trap right there and he kind of faked
them out with the tribbles nice knockout
and the Jazz go up five seven Trey's
good-looking free that time pray inside
staring at go bear dances around gets
back into the paint throws up a quick
one of it dropped in and a foul on Utah
the play here he just goes right by
Rubio stays with the dribble
they had them pretty much corralled
right there but Gobert goes back to his
man and it's too late and Trey had just
enough on it counted and a free throw to
come you know putting quarter a lot of
points in the first three minutes Trey a
sidestep three good hot shooting
continued great carries it over to the
right side working with Collins and has
switched out on Trey and Trey gets the
whistle count the basket and a free
throw to come burner looks blades it
into tray two seconds watch race
fluttered
[Applause]
deserve it again no help by JoEllen beef
[Applause]
[Music]
what a play by Trey young the Florida
that he has perfected and get all the
love on the sideline no man he's putting
together a heck of a game there's a
tenth of a second burger gets it in
damn it looking long to the basket away
[Applause]
[Music]
got it to his right hand beats the
plunger and then after two bounces three
it pulls in and Atlanta wins it in
overtime but basket is good great
trailing got it pops break it up young
comes away with it from Marietta
all away you know you got a shooter and
you Hawks get a steal here Trey young
someone has to pick them up and it flows
out a little bit closer yes no backed it
backed and all that stuff you can play
your starters a good 38 40 minutes I
still think you need to be effective in
your player absolutely
knows what he can do lead with a three
and Trey as that bounds in his step
makes the back
[Applause]
trae Young gets him out of their seats
one more time watch this fakes the
behind the back that goes through his
legs and drew the foul on Collison his
second number against Trey with 10 on
the shot clock
something moves in lost the ball Trey
comes up with it
and the Hawks look to push Evans went
for the slap and a foul didn't get the
whistle cross courts are harder for 3
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content